hey guys I'm Kate Lucy's on holiday
having a fabulous time in New York this
week so I'm filling in for her welcome
to in two minutes now who would have
ever thought that a film about the
heroic quest of a farmer who goes on to
save the galaxy would grow into one of
the most successful film franchises in
the world Star Wars is so incredibly
iconic that even just the sound of a TIE
fighter whooshing past which fYI is the
sound of an elephant mixed with a car
driving on a wet road sends shivers down
the spines of millions dices latest game
Star Wars Battlefront is stylistically
at least a master class in how to do
Star Wars right they will have to wait
until november seventeenth to find out
if it's always pretty as the beta was
for now we can confidently say that it
certainly sounds and looks a lot like
the Star Wars we know so here's a look
at the lens EA has gone to to make that
happen the team at dice consulted with
the original Star Wars sound design
legends Ben Burtt and matt wood to help
create the immersive soundscape you can
hear when playing the game everything
from the creak of an 80 80 s knees to
the air on Endor has been faithfully
recorded and recreated in true Foley
artist style by combining weird noises
until you get something unique and
memorable one particular ambient noise
was achieved by layering an ultra sound
recording over a faulty beer pump
because Foley artists are like the Willy
Wonka severe candy even if that does
sound super gross after air candy comes
I candy the star wars franchise has
hundreds of iconic vehicles outfits
weapons and locations and battlefront
uses these in spades with terabytes of
high-res photos original props and
costumes sources reference material the
game's artists use a technique called
photogrammetry which makes a high-res 3d
mesh using thousands of photos to get as
close to the source material as possible
it's time-consuming but worth it you
also have iconic characters like Luke
Vader and their lightsabers hopping
around the field like force enabled
frogs and smashing into each other at
clash of neon and in between all the
Jedi stuff you've got the huge clunking
march of the eighty 80s across the snowy
wastelands of Hoth the speeder bikes
darting through the trees on Endor and
the dogfights between Tie Fighters and
x-wings overhead with all the pew pew
noises to match there's a fair bit of an
homage to the original cinematography to
Star Wars loved it's screen wipes it's
fade to black sand long wide shots and
battlefront follows the same brief
capturing that 70s sci-fi feeling in
ways you might not even notice the
game's vistas are so wide and clear that
you can see Darth Vader bumbling around
a good two miles off ready for a good
sniper shot right to the helmet but when
you're not looking and hearing you're
feeling nearly everyone has grown up on
space epics and wanting to be han Solo
and star wars battlefront gives you the
things you've wanted since you were a
wee Padawan piloting x-wings & Tie
Fighters shooting your blaster from the
hip and taking down stormtroopers all
rebels if that's the way you swing the
Battlefront beta ended this week so
we'll have to wait another month to get
back to bouncing around half and finding
out just what the deal is with jakku and
that huge crash star destroyer maybe
it's just having a nap what did you
think of the Star Wars Battlefront beta
are you impressed with how much work
went into the making of the game let me
know in the comments below I'm Kate you
can find me on Twitter at how not to
draw and thanks for watching
you